there's no way wherever you go jj i'm
going to mess with you i had a look at
the face
this this point of we living in a
simulation
simple question who's the simulator yeah
god
i believe that
guys don't forget to check out god's
kicks inshallah it's run by a muslim
brother and sister
i'm going to earn a halal income check
out if you're interested in trainers
you've got some sick stuff there and
other stuff as well inshallah
assalamu alaikum brothers and sisters
and dear friends we've got a very
special video for you guys today on a
special day
yes you've got the dawah men reacting to
sidemen
we came across a very interesting video
uh brothers so basically they are
reacting to the universe so they're
seeing how
you know how big the earth is compared
to the sun compared to
the sun compared to the galaxy and
galaxy within another galaxy and all
kinds of words have been used here so
they're reacting and they are quite
amazed by this
and it's very interesting i think you
touched upon your video as well is that
you know they do gaming they do youtube
but for them to put that aside and be
like hold on a second actually
why we're here so then for them to look
for their purpose
brought us to this video and we want to
talk about the purpose of life so let's
react to this video in charlotte
brothers sisters
and we are going to hear some
interesting stuff from the sidemen and
then we're going to hear interesting
stuff
from the towerman let's go light years
away from us
to put that into perspective if it was
heading in the right direction
it would still take voyager 1 over 70
000 years to reach it in other words if
you drove your car
at 100 kilometers an hour like in our
previous example to the moon
it would take over six times longer than
the entire age of the universe
how does that understand how does that
exist well
the whole thing is it's mental in it
really it is it is
success and and like this like that we
can't be that many things it's
impossible
it has to be impossible well now it's
not impossible
i know that's the issue how scary is
that okay so one thing that really
caught my attention is their amazement
like all of them are just like
one one's got his hands one's like uh
what he says is like
we cannot be the only one here the first
thing that came to my mind hijab with
that was that for example when we say
you know alhamdulillah
or praise it belong to the lord of the
whole universe
and um i'm sure you know that the muslim
like
they say for example when this specific
verse is talking about
that they might they might be creatures
that we know of and not know we know the
gen kind we're not the mankind
but what else does like if you elaborate
on that you know when we say that
yeah very much so it could be that there
are other life forms on the
or in the universe yeah and um i don't
see why
he found that that was impossible uh but
yeah i mean that's certainly uh and if
it is the case then
the one who gave us life can give those
creatures life as well so the most
important thing to to note
i think which is a point of incredulity
i think where they were all kind of
fascinated by it
is that how is it the case that you can
have life form on
on the in the universe in the first
place you know how could there be life
what kind of universe does it have to be
in order to facilitate life in the first
place
and yeah how hostile would it have been
uh had it not been finely tuned in the
way it is
uh these are the questions let's carry
on inshallah 4.5 billion years for us to
pop up and
like the chances of us popping up is
like one in billions
given like we don't know anywhere else
let's say 4.5 billion years
yeah so yeah next week mars just pop up
like a little
tadpole thing and go yay but also how
we don't understand how that happens how
does it go from there's no life out of
those life there
here hijab he goes uh basically in the
question is
why is there existence rather no
existence
i think he's talking about life yeah in
particular the possibilities of life
being there yeah yeah
and for example the question is like is
it referring to it seems like you know
um why is there even existence in the
place well that's one of the things that
you know biologists and others talk
talk about something called abiogenesis
which is the
beginning of life and what what the
beginning of life actually is if you
think about it
is a movement from chemistry to biology
so you have these
these elements in the world what
happened in order to get
life from lifelessness because the truth
of the matter is
we've never seen it to be the case that
you can get properties from something
which doesn't have those properties in
other words something which doesn't have
life
cannot endow life in the case of
chemistry can't give life because it's
lifeless so and we say
that in order for life to be given it
has to be given from a life giver
exactly we say the life giver is the one
who's all living in this case it's god
right exactly
you know one thing that caught my
attention here is that they talk about
like 4.6 billion years and a lot of
people
atheists that we speak to agnostics they
talk about and they use time
as a factor of something coming into
existence so we say for example if we if
we have an
empty glass of argument's sake here time
is irrelevant to that if i said okay
okay if we gave it 4.6 billion years
what's the chances i'll get chocolate
strawberry cheesecake with four
strawberries on top of it
the time element is irrelevant because
some atheist uses and say
no no if you give it enough time this
will happen without no because the
the thing to make the chocolate the
ingredients that make the chocolate
flash cakes before strawberries
is not there what enough has time got to
do with it right right so if you keep
if you have lifelessness yeah uh in its
existence yeah so i'll
for as long as you leave it there it's
always going to remain as lifelessness
exactly that's why
once again the thesis you've got to
think about it rationally right from
from induction
or even from abduction influence to the
best explanation what makes more sense
to you this is the question people have
to ask that life was given
by a life giver which has life or that
it was given
or transferred from lifeless um
elements which in this case would be
chem chemistry and that's the best
influence like you said explain the best
inference yeah it gets a bit bizarre
because they actually
laugh at this concept let's carry on
let's carry it's really interesting
he spans over 100 000 light years from
end to end
there are over 100 billion stars and
over 100
billion planets inside of our galaxy
there's
no way wherever jj i'm going to mess
with you had a look at this right so you
know how you said
um that there has to be like other life
like we're just in the middle
yes here's a theory for you what if this
is a simulation
oh god you're way vic they created this
whole universe and they just put humans
in a little bit
let's see how far humans can go oh okay
isn't it interesting
that and i find this very amazing when i
speak to atheists i don't want to can
when we speak to them yeah
is that look at the options here it's
assimilation
or there's aliens how do you feel i can
you know when you hear that like
aliens or simulation but nowhere do they
fit in there the
possibility of being a creator like you
said yeah
how like what goes through your head
actually when you speak like eight or
you hear 80s or debates and discussions
and somebody's like it can be aliens
maybe they just put this here maybe it's
the matrix
maybe it's a simulation it's not it's
it's entertaining any other possibility
no matter how ludicrous it sounds other
than god
yes why because we've been conditioned
whether it's from the monty python days
or whether it's from the south parks and
the family guys or whatnot
religion has constantly been bashed yeah
and especially with how secular the
media is becoming especially bbc
and the main broadcasters and whether
you've got these nature
naturalists like um david attenborough
and all these guys
they they're all like richard dawkins
who says for example the why
question is very silly question sir the
why
question is just a silly question you
know basically saying be quiet
they accuse us of that as religious
people no but they're like don't ask
why i would say it's because of social
conditioning in other words that
religion has been seen to be uncool
aliens is cool
um simulation is cool because it's
associated to movies
it's associated to theories presented by
academics
even though if you actually look into it
certain academics they are theists like
isaac newton galileo
a lot of these academics in fact the
principia mathematica of isaac newton
yeah
yeah isaac newton was a theist so but
this isn't
even darwin if you read his book darwin
was like yes he had his moments but you
know
he was let's carry him one more one more
thing on this other
it's irrefutable to say okay now this
this point of
we living in a simulation simple
question who's the simulator yeah
exactly
wow exactly or even that's with aliens
what is the similarities you're creating
it doesn't have to be a who because they
can say that's presupposing um
you know personality so what we're
saying is that
the thing is actually the simulation
question that actually is more religious
than anything else they think that
they're getting out of things they're
getting
new things because if you say it's a
simulation then who's the simulator
there's number one question who's this
what who or what is a simulator yeah so
if you want to if you want to believe in
the simulation and you think it's a
plausible
option then you're halfway there exactly
and you know what if you think about
guys people watching
as you're watching us we need to finish
this video you're going to understand
that actually that is
logical reasoning yes but look what
happens next please
see where humans can get to look at this
this is and this is the observable
universe this is what we already
observed but we don't know
we don't know what the probability that
life comes about is yeah we have no clue
nothing's going on the thing is like all
we know is that there is life we don't
know where it came from why it exists or
what it is
we don't so what's to say that yeah it
could exist elsewhere but also we don't
know what makes life
everything else could be all dead it
could just be stuff it could just be all
like the rest of the matter
yeah just stuff we don't know
we we do we do know yeah
good
[Applause]
jesus we don't know that we don't
i think i'd feel much more at ease if i
believe that oh
good point here look let's bear in mind
the guy on the top right is a christian
yeah
he's made to feel a bit insecure even
though he's saying i believe that he's
laughing now yeah he should be laughing
he should be okay i believe that and i
think that's the best possible
explanation what i can't say is it's
very interesting yeah
firstly they have this they will give
them the benefit of that they were just
you know messing around joking etc
but this whole concept of god being
there and then you've got who's this guy
in the
vic star vic vicstar123 here four five
six
the thing is this guy at the bottom he's
totally kind of dismissing the concept
and i find it very bizarre and strange
the guy on the bottom right he seems
like he's fitting us in place where he's
saying
i would feel like at ease knowing that
knowing that god
created us that's the fitra speaking to
me here by
the innate disposition that we believe
as muslims were created to acknowledge
god
for them to look at the universe and be
amazed that
facial expressions to me is the feather
kicking in and saying wow
the guy at the top which we're going to
come to him there are christians he
believes in god anyways yeah
but how do you feel both of you i'll ask
you guys a question in the darwin how do
you feel about the reaction for example
him dismissing it he's saying that he
believes it and this guy at the bottom
or their whole concept of like this
whole good thing of
laughing about it i think it's it's an
interesting psycho
psychoanalytically obviously we're not
trying to psycho analyze them
but you can see that there's a
discomfort of mentioning the god topic
and even the fact that he's mentioned
that he's laughed after it
almost um feeling under pressure really
from from societal expectation which he
knows
peer pressure possibly that but he knows
also that the
recipients or the end users are going to
be mostly agnostic
and god is seen as a funny word now as
it seems uh
is a mythological concept so he thinks
that
positing it as a response is
unintellectual and he feels embarrassed
about it
and this guy the side boy in the far
left um he
he's just he's just being a fool i mean
to be honest with you he's trying to
offer something intellectual but
i think he's lacking in all rational
ability
because the thing is if you think about
what he said before uh
he kind of brushed god as a as a valid
option
he was saying that well we have all
these things which are just dead
dead things yeah but then the question
would be then how could life emerge from
death
right that's the question and he doesn't
seem to understand
that god is a reasonable okay option or
so this it's a way out of the dilemma
that he's facing it's actually the only
option
he's saying forget about the word god
you can say that a life
an entity which is living and has life
and has the ability to endow
others with life has done so that is
more befitting as a theory than saying
that life comes from death
if and if you do say that you're saying
that properties which exist
in in one form could ex could
come from something which doesn't have
those properties in the first place
which is
which is an impossibility exactly
logically we're talking i'd say he's
quite young academically
um maybe this is not something that he's
really looked into
and considering he's come from a
colonized curriculum in which let's face
it evolution is something which is
heavily promoted
and i mean the question would be is he
to blame
well now that he's actually put this out
there um
i think the burden of kind of
investigation is upon him
because he does have a big audience and
he owes it to his audience
to to study this stuff to learn about it
and not just rely on what he's been drip
fed
with the with the curriculum that we've
spoken and
whatever we get from mainstream media so
yeah
yeah interesting okay so let's finish
off with the last bit because you know
what this bit i want specifically
who's the guy's name on top right top
right is
toby okay i want to message the toe
because i know he's going to be watching
this here guys i need to go and pray
i'll catch you guys later okay that
shows to me through their reaction how
magnificent the creator is and they see
themselves as
you know absolutely nothing you know and
when he said i want to go and pray it's
i felt like he was
overwhelmed by what he saw and he was
like man i was a muslim at first when i
first started this guy's a muslim yeah
so i want to send a message to toby yeah
because toby's a christian
and christian i don't know which
denomination you belong to but i'm sure
again in our concept in
islamically there's shirk involved
associated partners to god which is a
massive sin and toby if you're watching
this what you just saw of the universe
how big the universe is the galaxy and
everything that's in it
as a christian you was amazed by god's
power
but as a christian you associate that to
jesus
everything that you saw you're saying
all that that was create everything
jesus was a part of that jesus played
the role in the christian because he's
god i want you to understand
and i want everyone to understand as
muslims because tahiti is the
fundamental principles and i want to end
on this note
is that can you imagine and this is why
we believe shirk
is the most disgusting thing that anyone
can ever do
because everything that you saw in that
universe and there's little spark and
stars and galaxies and you'll be more
amazed that it goes out and out
and you're saying oh my gosh we can't be
the only one it is such a sinful thing
such a disaster
that we go and ascribe that to a statue
we go and ascribe that to jesus we're
going to describe that to a human being
to a creation
brothers and sisters we are asking
people christians whether you are to
worship god alone what you saw that he
was amazed with
that is the creator that is deserving of
worship that is the creator
that is deserved of your servitude
brothers and sisters
and that's the reason why to my
christian provinces that are watching
this
you guys ascribe that to a human being
in that speck of creation
you're saying god almighty you created
all of that came to that little speck of
dust
inside and died brother and sisters
thank you it
was absolutely a pleasure for your uh
contribution and see sean
brothers one thing we request from you
guys and sisters please send this to the
side men
and let them watch inshallah from the
darwin